[Music]
sakura's new free update introduces
gauntlets of strength which are four
boss rush challenges that lead to
new skins and a really good new weapon
art
if you're able to beat all of their
bosses without dying
so first let's go over the rewards then
we'll go over the new law
the new boss variants and at the end of
the video i'm gonna try and do live
commentary for the first time
just showing you how i like to beat all
of these bosses
so this is sakura dance a new weapon art
that you'll receive if you defeat the
three bosses in the divine air gauntlet
it is unabashedly in my opinion the most
powerful weapon art in the game just
look at this footage
i feel like this is from software saying
hey gauntlets are pretty damn hard
you should probably take this for the
low cost of one spirit emblem
sakura dance propels you high into the
air allowing you to dodge
most ground attacks with three large
sweeping slashes
from which you can transition into any
mid-air prosthetic attack
so you can slam down with the loaded axe
you can start a sabi maru combo
or throw some firecrackers just be
creative as if that wasn't enough though
sakura dance also
reflects lightning easily too which
as we'll get into later is pretty damn
good against some of the new bosses
so let's talk about the gauntlets and
their rewards on your way to one of the
main endings you will unlock the
severance gauntlet
which if beaten will reward you with the
memories of the tengu outfit
which belonged to ishin just completing
the game will also unlock the
ashina outfit which belonged to the
sculptor back in the days when
he was called sekijo the one armed
orangutan
we get to see what he looked like which
is pretty cool now because some bosses
are unique to different endings and you
need to defeat the bosses to unlock the
gauntlets
you'll have to go into new game plus at
some point if you want to unlock all the
gauntlets
on one character for example to unlock
the shura gauntlet you'll have to kill
all the bosses
on the way to the shura ending but
you'll also have to kill
our father who is actually a part of the
purification ending
once you unlock and overcome the shura
gauntlet you'll be rewarded with
the memory of shura outfits which is by
far the best new skin in my opinion
because it gives us an insight into what
our
harrowing life must be like after
becoming shura
and you might remember during the shura
ending the narrator tells of our
subsequent
murderous rampage throughout the ashina
countryside
very few people survived so this outfit
is actually based on their memories
and it's told via ashina folk song
fields of bodies
mountains of dead down dragon spring
river our country bled
a fiery god demon wolf in red also if
these outfits aren't enough for you i
also recently released
zip hoodie variants of all of my merch
just saying
so i want to talk about memories now and
the outfits aren't the only new memories
that you'll receive
for sekiro his memories are actually
somewhat
physical as is evidenced by the fact
that you can
take items from them back into the world
with you
even though these memories are just a
recollection of something that's already
happened
now after countless recollections of the
bosses in
secular's own memory the remnants of
these bosses
have physically and mentally as well
grown
stronger as a result of all of those
recollections
and this is all happening within the
inner confines
of our memory so this is inner genichiro
a young genitiro watched as turmoil
danced
her movements held secrets and a height
of technique that not even a lifetime
could attain
and yet in memory after countless bounce
with his
mortal enemy genitaro at last reached
those heights
inner ganichiro's new moveset is one of
the better move sets added to the game
in my opinion
because his new moves often subvert your
expectations
he now has gap closers new flurries the
sakura dance combat art that does
chip damage if you don't deflect it and
best of all
a new lightning reversal so that's right
when you play the you know reverse card
and you reflect genitalia's lightning
he then says no you then he also
reflects that lightning
back at you and from there you can
reverse his reversal of your reversal
ending this incredible lightning tennis
match in style
as mentioned earlier this is why sakura
dance is actually a very welcome
new addition to the game though if you
don't have that equipped it's probably
better to just
dodge through his lightning attacks now
to avoid playing the game
at all next inner father al inner father
al once abandoned the young wolf
in yusui forest expecting him to fend
against the illusions
likely never to return only in victory
would he recognize the boy
as his son in this way and in this way
alone
he raised the wolf as his own it
confirms what we already knew
that al was a father to secure to force
a pursuit of strength
and in no other way his new moveset is
at its best when it subverts your
expectations again
like the fire owl in phase two that he
throws sideways now
sometimes to catch you jumping over it
like you used to have to do
he also has some new combos and i love
when you attack him and he turns into
the missed raven and you really have to
watch out for that during your
aggression
getting hit in new ways has never been
so much fun
lastly inner eachine which i personally
feel like is the most disappointing new
variant
just because the new moves are kind of
just additions to his
already enormous moveset but i will say
his new opening attack is really cool
if you time it right you can sort of run
right back into
the eye of the storm all his life ishin
sought opponents whom he could face in a
battle to the death
it would be foolish to believe that his
thirst could be sated in memory to face
the one who cut him down
how the blood boils at the thought when
you beat all of the gauntlets
and all of the new bosses you'll unlock
the mortal journey
here you'll have to face 17 main bosses
including the three new boss variants
all in a row without dying by the way
this is the hardest challenge you can do
in the game and if you complete it
your reward awaits you in the
dilapidated temple
you get nothing nothing except the
memory of an incredible journey
which considering we've been talking
about memories this entire video
it's actually a pretty fitting reward in
my opinion i
had such a blast practicing and
overcoming this content on stream with
you guys i'll never forget the first
moment kenichiro reflected my lightning
when i desperately needed to get a kill
on the second ape
before its posture went down or when my
two-year-old son arlo
burst into the room during the final
boss fight of the mortal
journey hi arlo do you want to come in
if you're considering attempting these
challenges just make sure you pick up
all the prayer beads as you head into
new game plus
because your health relates to your
character but your attack power doesn't
so don't worry about that
it's possible that these fights are
affected by new game plus but i'm
actually not sure yet
maybe try not to go too high into new
game plus unless you can confirm
otherwise
and shout outs to all the channels that
helped me learn how to defeat these
bosses
they're in the description watching all
these folks helped me
form my own personal strategies for
dealing with all the bosses and
that's what i'm going to try and teach
you all now enjoy
and good luck if you attempt this
yourself i highly recommend giving it a
shot
all right so this is like my third
attempt recording this i was originally
going to narrate over it in post
but then i realized all of my individual
boss recordings
i didn't have audio and you want audio
for these because you want to be able to
hear
all of the like ting ting of the
successful parries and you want to be
able to hear cues and that sort of thing
so i'm also going to turn off the music
turning off the music is actually
something you could also do if you want
to just
you know focus on the gameplay so i'd
kind of
recommend that honestly if you're
practicing even though the music is
incredible
but we're going to start off with a
gauntlet of strength here we're going to
do the divine air gauntlet
and we're going to start with gyobu who
is
really one of the easiest bosses in the
game
you know he's the first boss and there's
very little he can do to threaten you
as you'll see and if you play it
correctly there's honestly very little
boss
in general so get five hits off here
and then use firecrackers and you can
keep attacking if you're lucky you can
get seven attacks here i think
state a medium distance then you can get
that grapple mid-air attack one extra
attack
and after you do about 15 attacks or so
he usually gets stun locked
um i think it's around 15. so i'm just
standing at medium distance here
trying to exploit these grapples and now
i kind of want to get hit
so to get hit you stay on his right side
and you get some nice parries in in
secular remember a lot of the time the
goal is actually to get hit so you can
parry
um helps you learn their attacks as well
and in phase two i'll show you some
cheese
if you really want to beat this fight
with like no chance of failure
so same principles if he gets that far
do that
and now i'm just going to show you what
happens if you just hold block
gyobu cannot break your guard to the
best of my knowledge if you just hold
block
his attacks do a lot of damage if they
hit you
but they don't do that much posture
damage and there's so
long of a break in between them that you
can just hold block and wait for a safe
time to attack him if you really want to
it was actually an accident for me to
use the weapon out there because i'm not
used to holding clock
but you know we'll fight him normally
until you want to use firecrackers then
it's not normal anymore firecrackers are
amazing in this fight
after you do the second firecrackers
though he will start doing a slam attack
um so be aware of that but
yeah firecrackers every 20 seconds or so
and this is a piece of cake
camera is always what gets killed though
in the situations
if you're against the wall it's good
because he can run
into the wall but it's bad because your
camera can get stuck
so yeah that's pretty much the fight um
it's more fun to learn the parries he
has a lot of very predictable attacks
and that's goboo man
i actually just finished doing this
gauntlet before i realized that my
recording was messed up
um you also want to rest in between
that's something that i often forget to
do
um not that it matters too much but
something to be aware of
now lady butterfly lady butterfly is a
hard boss for being such an early boss
but there is one thing
you can do or rather not do to make her
very easy
and that is don't attack don't attack
attacking makes this boss so much harder
and i'll show you why
also a [ __ ] equip your shurikens and
just get in a face and tap block
so unlike yobu where we were holding
block i'm just tapping block here
and when i say tap block i don't mean
like mindlessly tap it
i mean tap it constantly but
try to time it where she hits you so
tap it but sort of try to tap it a
little bit in sync with her attacks
and by doing this there's virtually no
chance
that she'll ever hit you there's
virtually no chance that she'll really
ever break your posture
but look at her posture out of all the
bosses in the game
lady butterflies posture recovers very
slowly even because even when at full
health
um so yeah that's
that's pretty much it attacking her is
hard because
finding a good flow with your attacks is
difficult because she attacks so quickly
sometimes
so she'll kind of like um
she becomes twice as complicated if you
do attack her so if you're not confident
you can get by just blocking her and
then also shurikens when she jumps on
the wire
be aware that it's shuriken time you
also want to dodge through that
triple attack it's very obviously
telegraphed so as soon as you see her
knees bend that means she's going to
jump off
and you can get a free attack in
but yeah i'll show you the cheese as
well
uh maybe i can show it to you now so if
you're really having a hard time
i'll try to show you the cheese in the
next phase hopefully it goes well
there is one cheesy thing you can do
that makes this fight a bit of a joke
and basically what you do to cheese her
is you just attack
dodge attack dodge attack dodge so when
you get an attack in dodge
and you want to just repeat this and
it's basically impossible for her to
break it
um of course she cast this
so that does break it but that's pretty
rare for that to happen
if you have snap seeds which you should
run into the middle of them and you can
dispel them all at once
but i'll also show you how to um
i'll show you how to deal with those if
you don't have snapseeds so this is the
cheese
dodge attack dodge attack and it's very
difficult for her to break out of it
it's very difficult for her to damage
you although it can happen
so yeah the other thing in this phase
is that she summons butterflies and when
she summons butterflies
what you want to do is you want to jump
backwards and to an angle and i'm not
getting a good example of it here but it
does happen fairly frequently
in this phase and we want to try and get
her to do that so i can show you
um also the pause button is amazing in
sakura
you don't even need to necessarily have
snapseeds on your hotbar
so i really want her to use the
butterflies now and once you get this
down
all you end up being aware of is just
holding tapping block
dodging backwards from the butterflies
and looking out for her unblockables
which can be pretty easily telegraphed
but
most of them just involve jumping over
so there's the butterflies
i'm just holding back and jump at an
angle and then after three jumps
backwards
she'll almost always do a jump attack
there's her triple attack
and yeah that's lady butterfly
the core of it is just stay on the
defense
tap block and then after you've got that
down you can
dedicate you know the rest of your mind
towards
avoiding her really obvious attacks like
the sweep
and the triple attack and the
butterflies
good luck so next up is gennichiro
i thought this bite was easy the first
time i did it but it's one of the harder
inner fights he has a lot of new attacks
and they kind of
if you're really used to the previous
way to fight kenichiro these new attacks
are actually quite
difficult to deal with because they
really throw you for a loop and
surprise you you want to have
firecrackers in my opinion
firecrackers are overpowered for
basically every fight and you get really
good at using them after a while
so firecrackers are good and also if you
have this
equip sakura dance is actually amazing
against any type of lightning attack in
the game
it counters it pretty much completely
for free and without any real timing
needed
um but you do unlock this when you
finish this gauntlet so a lot of you
might not have this unlocked yet
so you don't really need it but it is
good so
i'm going to pretend we don't have it
for now and
i'm going to show you in the second
phase you just want to dodge through his
lightning
and not use this so
that's one of his new attacks the triple
you want to parry it perfectly
always be on the lookout for those
mckitties and let me just run around and
talk about him for a bit so ganichiro's
battle flow
is different than the previous two and
every boss fight has like a battle flow
to it right like
uh gyobu you just basically block
through his attacks and look for really
obvious openings lady butterfly you just
basically
tap block and look for obvious openings
but denitro is my favorite battle flow
and the battle flow is sort of
its attack until you get parried and
then defend
until you parry him and
just rinse and repeat so i'll try get
into a good loop with him and show you
what i mean
attack attack until i get parried and
then i go on the defensive
so you might have seen it there um
they'll probably be a better example
sometimes you can get into a really long
battle flow with konichiwa
but it's not really happening here
unfortunately um
but there it is so attack till you get
parried and then just deliberately press
attack till you get parried
and then go on the defensive so yeah
hopefully you know what i mean by
battleflow but i'm going to start the
fight again so we get more practice in
and i'm just going to try and comment on
what is happening on screen now so that
was his triple attack
it's very obviously foreshadowed
you want to do the triple block against
it
like that um
and basically with nature you want to
stay pretty aggro because he's pretty
dangerous at a distance with his bow and
especially in a
ganesha he has a lot more gap closing
attacks
so
so you can get into this loop very often
and i'm just deliberately tapping r1
until i get parried
don't spam my one deliberately tap it
each time
that's a really good example of the loop
you can get in with kenichiro just
attack attack parry defender parry
attack attack parry it just goes on and
on
but now let's try and talk about some of
his other attacks when he jumps
backwards like that
very often he'll pull out out his bow
and you want to
dodge into him when he jumps backwards
and sometimes he actually gets in a loop
where he just keeps trying to pull out
his bow
like this he's going to pull out his bow
if you dodge towards him more accurately
that won't hit you
so his flurries are very dangerous in
this too um
there's a lot of new attacks to do with
his flurries if you see him starting a
flurry the best thing to do is actually
firecracker him
yep there's the bow i'm gonna get a heel
in here instead
so yeah once you get the battle flow
down you can start to look out for his
other attacks and learn them
and honestly you want to practice
against regular guinea first
because inner genital has a lot of new
moves and it can make it a bit more
complicated
so this is his flurry that's what i mean
by firecrackering it
i could have beaten him much faster in
the first phase when he runs to the side
like that he's always doing a sweep
and sometimes you'll get hyper armor
like that afterwards
but you can be aware of the sweep and
jump on top of it it does the jump in
the air
uh dodge the side of it
so the way to heal against him
is to wait until he's doing another
animation and then he'll
otherwise he'll close that gap really
quickly and interrupt you
so this is where we can talk about the
lightning attacks i actually don't want
to do too much damage because i want him
to do the lightning attacks
um so i can show them to you let me just
pause
so if you don't have this just
dodge through the lightning attacks and
i'll show you what that means
like that wait for them to hit you then
dodge through it
because if you reflect the lightning
attacks
he will now in inner ganesha mode
he will now
he will reflect them back at you so you
have to reflect them twice
so you play lightning tennis with him
but if you have sakura dance
and i'll show you what i mean by sakura
dance being amazing
i actually don't want to kill him here
i'm gonna sakura dance his next
lightning attack
and i'm gonna skip forward to when that
landing attack actually happens
any second now gennady okay there it is
basically if you see lightning you can
use sakura dance and you will
counter it 100 of the time basically
sakura dance as a weapon art
sakura dance as a webinar is just it's
their from software's gift to you for
giving you such hard gauntlets to defeat
so yeah you want to equip
sakura dance that's that's a good tip
but um
it's just amazing man it's incredible
i'll show it to you quickly
it can get you over other enemies you
can use prosthetic arts in the middle of
it
it reflects lightning it's just
broken so next we'll do severance
this is probably the hardest gauntlet of
strength i think
because it's also the longest um
but it's fun guardian ape is fun
so guardian ape you have a really big
opportunity to get ready
at the start of this fight and by get
ready i mean buff your character
but the prosthetics you want are
firecracker
you want to have the flame vent and you
want to have loaded spear
preferably the low level loaded spear so
it doesn't use
very much spirit emblems and then at the
start of this fight you can just start
buffing
so put on an ako sugar so you can get
some more damage
use a divine confetti and also
equip oil on your hot bar if you have it
oil makes this first phase go so quickly
and honestly if i do this right
this will be over before you know it so
as i'm running towards him as soon as he
sees me i'm gonna struck some oil at him
and before he can hit me i'm hopefully
gonna hit him with this
and burn him i'm gonna switch to my
firecrackers
and use them here and i'm just gonna go
to town and this should stun him soon
there it is and with any luck
he'll also be very stunned soon with any
luck
yeah see there we go there's the big
stun and now
he's almost dead and i've barely done
any fight here
if he does the running attack you just
run away from it
and now you can do if you it depends on
how much health you have left but this
fight's almost over
basically you vary between using long
spark and fire
so i'm going to use long spark here you
can use it about once every 20 seconds
after the first one he does a slam
attack so be aware of that
and then it's on cooldown so i'm going
to switch to the oil
and i'm going to use the fire instead
wait until you get an opportunity to use
the fire
and then he does this as well so
it depends on how much health you have
left after that intro sequence but
you can vary between those two things
and just constantly keep him stun locked
uh if you don't do that the fight's
pretty hard um
he does a lot of posture damage and
damage and his moveset's pretty
unpredictable
um so i'd recommend doing that in the
gauntlet at least
but i'm talking as if the fight's over
and that's because it basically is this
this
this phase is just easy the reason you
might think this phase is hard is
because you probably haven't had much
practice at it
because the first phase often beats
people
but you just want to parry the sword
until he does the slam double tap your
spear
to pull out the centipede and that does
a huge amount of posture damage
when he screams runs straight behind him
the hitbox of the scream
is actually really small behind him but
it's really large in front of him
he jumps in the air you just jump when
you see the warning symbol
and now it's again one of those
situations where we just want to get hit
so we can get our parries in the more of
these you parry the more likely it is
he'll do that
and the more he does that the faster the
boss fight ends
there are a few things to watch out for
i guess um but most of them in this
phase are just
sweeps that you jump over like so that
was good timing
so whenever you see a warning sign in
this phase it generally just means
time to jump and that's it
the loaded spear makes this so easy
i gotta say since there were all these
new boss fights in this gauntlet
i was kind of hoping there would be like
a third
phase of the ape can you imagine they
just add a secret third
phase to mess with you so what's next
great shinobi owl okay
so firecrackers are kind of the best
thing for this fight but honestly
it's not really a prosthetic heavy fight
the very easy way to defeat this
is by staying at a medium distance and
dodging through his attacks
so i'll show you that now medium
distance
that's an exploitable attack get back to
your medium distance
and that's an exploitable attack just
dodge through it
you basically dodged through any of his
sweeps and any of his jump attacks
see if i'd spaced that properly i
wouldn't have got hit
[Music]
and yeah so all
is one of those fights you want to deal
health damage to him early
you don't really want to worry about his
posture at all because
unlike lady butterfly his posture will
come back very quickly
um unless you do some significant health
damage he can follow up sometimes when
you're behind him so be aware of that
um like here and
if you run away too early also get
caught i got hit on purpose there so you
can see that
but generally in this arena you want to
heal when they're busy doing some other
animation
otherwise you will get punished severely
so yeah when you're behind him be wary
that he can follow up and that's when
you tap block to parry
um you can also exploit that healing
attack but i'll get into that in a
second
but he's almost half health now i'm just
dodging through all his sweeps
staying at a medium distance when i can
and if you're confident you can fight
him normally here so let me
sort of show you what that looks like
the thing is when you fight al normally
this fight becomes a lot more
complicated so
if you really want to cheese it you just
played a medium distance until he's
out of health like you never worry about
his posture at all
but it's a really fun fight to learn how
to do this
like he's got a lot of very fun sword
play that you can encounter
um obviously that stops you that's like
a lloyd's talisman
stops you from healing second phase is
okay when he does that unlock and
go behind him and do what i just did
there so hopefully we get another
example
before the fight's over but basically by
doing that
you get two extra hits in whenever he
does that green orb attack
so you can use this opportunity to buff
if you want to um
hey if you want you can also maybe throw
some oil at him
okay i'm actually not sure if you can
this is probably not the best time
to test new strategies yeah no you can't
never mind
all right phase two unlock
attack behind him and you can clip him
twice with your sword
same principles in this phase except the
poison can make your
uh middle medium distance strategy a
little bit harder
because the arena's covered in poison
but
you can still do it if you want to if
you don't feel confident just cheese him
at a medium distance
and get a ton of health damage on him
but i'm gonna try and fight him normally
so okay that's not good
same thing though that poison's actually
pretty brutal in this game so i will
heal it
um
pretty good to have some antidote powder
just in case
but let me fight him normally maybe not
talk for a minute
so i can get some actual skill back
i never really record and talk live
unless i'm on stream
that's another thing you can do in this
phase which is annoying get his posture
back
more often than not honestly with al
you'll just beat him by um
just depleting his health because
posture can be tough
it's just amazing you don't get that
many openings for his health unless you
do the medium distance strap um
i actually don't have healing equipped
here okay funnily enough that's a good
opportunity to heal
yeah i'm just so aware of those attacks
that you can dodge through
and it looks like posture is not going
to be a factor here he's being very
generous with his
openings today
when he does that just try to look
through the smoke as you
clearly as you can often he'll just
follow up with a sweep attack
which is good for you obviously but it
can be hard to see sometimes
so this is a long phase two
because we kind of like oh yeah
firecrackers
you never really used firecrackers it's
pretty rare honestly
but you want to dodge through them if
you can and you get a free hidden
so just dodge towards him kind of thing
all right kind of a scuffed owl fight
but there was a lot to learn there and
there's a cheese strategy if you want to
and there's also just
learning is attacks and i recommend
learning his attacks because
you're probably going to want to know
them when you fight al
father later on which is something
you're going to be
fighting twice because there's also the
inner owl
variant but for now we will do true
monk one of my favorite fights in the
game because i have very fond nostalgic
memories of it
at gamescom like
just remembering going to games come
playing this game before it was out
and no one knew what the hell to do
against this
this boss because no one knew how to
really parry but you can chase it very
easily with firecrackers
let me show you the cheese
so firecrackers attack attack
firecrackers
attack attack and you can keep doing
that i forgot to rest at the idol so i
actually don't
have um as many firecrackers as i would
like to have
but you want to use the firecracker
straight at the start if you're gonna
use it anywhere
because um you start doing health damage
and makes a lot easier to get her
posture down
so let me get some more firecrackers
here by using the ceremonial tanto
but this is another fight i kind of just
recommend you learn it because it's so
much fun
but if you do need to cheese it the
firecrackers plus a bath
will deplete her health so fast
that's fast
but the second cheese in this phase is
after you defeat first phase
go to the far end of the arena look up
at this tree
grapple up there quickly look down lock
on
and jump and you completely negate the
second phase
in the third phase that comes out
you want to equip the confetti you can
buff you can throw oil you have plenty
of time
she'll always open up with this you can
jump through or sorry
dodge through the fifth sweep and
honestly you can use firecrackers again
if you want to
just look at all the health damage this
does don't do the follow-up attack from
the firecrackers it's actually better to
just do a double attack
and yeah this fight is like almost over
by virtue of
how much health damage we've done
her posture will go up very quickly but
other than that
man this is just such a fun fight to
learn how to block
it's such a fun flow to it
whenever she does the um centipede
attack
just dodge the side watch out for makiri
and watch out for sweep attacks i don't
really know
what else to say other than watch out i
guess if you want
you can go back and watch the stream
like in slow motion
and then you can sort of get a good idea
of what the obvious tells are for those
attacks
i just kind of know them in the back of
my mind but
over time you will learn what to look
out for that's
most of where practice comes into the
into it
so that's true monk and this time i'm
going to rest
at the idol because that's something you
want to do
okay another easy fight
kenichiro way of term away this is
we did inuishin ichiro before and this
is just such a cakewalk compared to that
he'll always open with this get behind
him
whenever he's doing it and you won't get
hit
and this is actually a better example of
the battleflow thing i was talking about
this fight usually has a very obvious
sort of flow to it
i'm gonna run away from that oh there's
a rock in the way
watch me die whenever you heal he likes
to do mercury so be aware of that
let's see if we can get him into a good
loop he ran to the side so he did a jump
mercury very obvious
[Music]
he's actually acting quite strangely in
this fight he's doing a lot of special
attacks
um normally there's a lot more swordplay
in this
all right well that's way of turmoil i
guess man i keep trying to explain to
you guys like
for battleflow ghanichiro fights but
ganitra was like nah mate
not doing that
all right so the last fight is inner
ishin inuishin
is one of the more disappointing inner
variants
um unlike the others they don't really
switch up the way you
are supposed to fight him in a very big
way you kind of just run away from any
attack you don't recognize
he'll always start with this though
so get medium distance for the first one
then run inside
and you get a free attack in and
the battle flow i'm going to talk about
it again i know i keep saying battle
flow
the battleflow for this fight is attack
attack parry
attack attack parry and you'll see what
i mean
until you see like special attacks like
that
attack okay that was a new attack i
wasn't
familiar with what that was so i'm gonna
run away and heal
when he goes to the side like that he
usually does a mercury attack
when he does um the sword back you can
be in his face and block
like that when he pulls his sword back
like that and you'll always be mercury
after it
another one is if he sheaths his sword
you also get in his face and tap block
and then you can jump on his head um so
whenever he sheaths his sword
or does the obviously mercury thing you
kind of like block the first one and
then
follow up with like this one
he sheathed his sword so i knew i had to
jump on his head
there that one he pulled his sword back
so i blocked it and then i
did the makiri so those are two ones you
want to be very aware of because
you get some good punishes in yep see
this sword go in his face block
jump on his head up again
in his face block jump on his head
oh he really showed them off for you
guys
so yeah he did the stab there
you can actually use firecrackers at the
start of this phase
um maybe i'll show you that cheese on
screen right now
and if you do that you get a lot of free
health damage in but
yeah that's one of his new attacks again
i don't know these
i'm not really sure how to counter them
but generally i just run away
if i can so this fight
attack dodge through this attack once
never attack more than once generally
and you can get into this loop
where you attack him and then block and
if you get a successful parry you can
get him into a nice loop
damn those attacks are pretty brutal but
i'ma heal through them
when he does the spin like that it's a
double block and then run away
this is always a horizontal sweep attack
once
block attack once dodge through attack
once
block attack once block attack once
you can block that as well if you want
to attack once
block attack once dodged through attack
once
block so if you miss the perfect parry
he starts comboing
that's why you want to parry every time
so attack perfect block attack
attack perfect block attack jump through
attack jump through attack perfect block
that's you see what i mean this is kind
of like the loop for this second phase
and sometimes it can go on for quite a
while and you actually once until you
bail it when you fail it
run away and start again this is a
mercury
sometimes he misses you completely which
is weird and it can throw you off
whenever he does the charge like that
just run away because this is one of
those attacks like
oh i wish he wasn't dead there yeah
whenever he does that charge i should
just
really run away but i'm still learning
it
tap block for the glock and let's finish
him off without talking otherwise i will
fail
okay i thought maybe i could oh this is
not good i might die
okay hmm
maybe you guys can figure out how to um
solve that attack
it's probably easier when you're
watching the youtube video
i actually don't know quite yet
almost there
oh we got glocked but it's all right
okay
so we have a resurrection back now now
the third phase can be easier in a way
because he does lightning attacks
and during this initian you should have
sakura dance
so that's sakura dance in action
basically i mean
whenever you see lightning use your
weapon on that's it
whenever you see that charge attack
you're supposed to run to the left
and yeah i'm just using sucker dance man
it's so good
don't run off the cliff that's the thing
always
is it was actually a strategy to you
know spawn far away from him and heal
oh my god is that attack again i've been
hit by this tech more in this youtube
tutorial than any other time
so same principle in the last phase is
in the second phase you can get him into
this loop
just be aware that he's gonna use
lightning more often
and you know in a way the lightning is
actually a good thing because it's just
so counterable
and that's the fight man that's it
so a little bit scuffed in the first
phase but we brought it back
so that's the second gauntlet severance
and that's ishin and can i just say it's
so
fitting to fight him with the shura skin
i love it okay so the last gauntlet
is the shura gauntlet
quite short but full of quite difficult
bosses
except for emma let's be honest
so emma has a very similar principle to
lady butterfly
in that you can just tap block and
virtually never lose this fight tap
block and then devote the rest of your
memory
and mind to avoiding her other attacks
like this one which you dodged to the
side
but just look at the her posture bar and
mine
attack if she does nothing but other
than that i mean i should have jumped on
top of that but you can also dodge it to
the side
because the sword is so short
and you're starting to understand the
reason you do want to attack her
sometimes
is because it might stop her posture
from coming back
but other than that that's obviously
makiri because she's doing the stab
that's a sweep because she has a sword
to the side
the reason you also want to block is
because she has that double attack
which makes it just more complicated if
you do decide to attack her
man this animation always makes me sad
feels bad man but
feels good man we beat it ishin ashina
a variant on ishin sword saint that has
a few
unique quirks that can sort of trip you
up sometimes
but generally is a much easier fight
like it's basically phase one of ishiin
sword saint
and i'll show you the loop you want to
get into
so if you see him she this sword
remember get in his face
spam block until you block it if he does
eat your mongi just wait until you can
block it
and i'll show you what i mean about this
fight
being one that can trip you up if you
attack him while he's not doing anything
he actually sidesteps your attack so if
you're attacking him from idle
never do more than one attack i'll see
if i can show you
see that and he'll almost always follow
it up with a sort of
uh spin sweep attack which isn't really
a sweepy jump on but
yeah when he does that walk to the side
he always does mercury
so yeah if you attack him from idle be
aware
that he will dodge it
wait until he goes on the downswing for
that it's very easy
and yeah see so i know whereas in the
other fight i will be more aggressive
when he's idle this one i'm always aware
that he can
sidestep my sword like that and if he
does that same as emma just dodged the
side
yeah see i [ __ ] up there because i
attacked him from idol
it would be really bad to die here
so he shaved his sword so i got in his
face
and now i'm just trying to get my health
back so i can finish him off
and then we'll talk about phase two so
get in his face whenever he shoots his
sword
whenever he does an obvious mercury you
also want to
block the first part and then mercury it
like this so that was it there
that's it there again block the first
stab and then mercury the second one
and i mean you basically do this in the
second phase but the second phase is
different
make sure you have firecracker
and even just the basic umbrella
and you want the umbrella for this
attack so he's doing it right now
he's doing he does this really long
charge and you can either
either use the firecracker to interrupt
it or you can use the umbrella
to nullify it so he does this
stand where somewhere where it's not on
fire
and then use the umbrella i did not
stand in the right spot but if you do
that attack will not hit you
so the different thing in this phase is
these things i'm getting hit by non-stop
um and they're actually a good thing
like eachine's lightning attacks
the fire attacks are actually just
good so whenever he raises his knee like
that
dodge to the right twice and you will
always dodge it
okay always to the right
that's his charge i'm using the
firecrackers this time
because apparently i suck at using the
umbrella when he walks to the right
same as before he's mercury
he raised his leg if you're far away
from any emmy raises his leg just jump
around
to the side
and be aware of that sidestep attack he
sheathed his sword
so i dodged it i mean i blocked it
yep he raised his leg so i knew i had to
go to the side
he's doing a charge attack so i need to
use firecrackers now the one thing with
this fight
is you never want to fight him near the
walls because it makes it
hard to dodge to the right whenever he
does a fire attack
so that's why he's over there now i want
him in the middle of the arena when he
does that
downside is he'll get his posture back
but
yeah it's also better not to attack him
oh [ __ ] i actually don't
no i don't know what that attack was i
think it was a sweep
anyway i'll stop talking now in focus
that was a stab so block the first stab
mercury the second one remember that
his knee goes up dodged to right twice
knee went up dodges to the right
doing the charge
actually since this fight's about to end
let me show you what the charge attack
does look like
so i'll skip forward to when he does do
the charge attack and i won't mess up
the umbrella
because sometimes you'll forget to do
the firecrackers you know
okay so he's finally doing the charge
attack look for a bit without fire
stand in it use the umbrella
wait for it all to finish and then you
can follow up with an attack
the umbrella honestly the umbrella strap
might do more damage
than the firecrackers do so it's up to
you which one you want to use but
if you have both of them equipped you
have options so
that is the eachine fight but
it's actually not the hardest thing in
this run
honestly the hardest boss that they've
added is probably inner owl
inner al
is not the next fight demon of hatred is
so i forgot
what do demon of hatred next demon of
hatred is like
think of it like a dark souls boss in
sakura
that's why a lot of people lose to this
fight so to make it easy
you want to have a few things you want
to have
this suzaku's lotus umbrella and you
want to have
malcontent you don't need these but
unlike any other fight in the game
except maybe the guardian ape
these make the fight so easy you also
want to have
a couple of buffs you want to have
divine confetti
you want to have ako sugar and you
actually want to have yash riku sugar as
well if you can
this is one of those situations where
this is actually very good to use
sometimes
um that's it i'll show you how to beat
it without these as well but
they do make it much easier it has also
just occurred to me that i forgot to
rest
and so i will be doing this with two
healing gourd
if you have a lot of confetti you can
use it at the start here but other than
that pull out your umbrella
and basically when he does a fire attack
use your umbrella
when he does a leg attack or a non-fire
attack
parry it and that's the principle for
the entire fight
and because i messed up
i might also need to use the ceremonial
tanto to get more
uh weapon weapon arts so i've kind of
messed up this fight already
man it really screws you over when you
don't heal at the statue
this this is one of his combos um
umbrella parry parry umbrella is how
that one
goes but the umbrella just puts so much
damage on him when he uses fire attacks
man it's insane it makes you completely
safe
as long as you have if he does that
attack
usually does that when you're running
towards him but if you see him do it
and you're close to him it actually
won't hit you
[Music]
so now we have a lot of time to buff so
i am going to use the ceremonial tensor
because you won't have you should maybe
use the ceremonial tanto it'll make sure
you never run out of umbrella
umbrellas but you don't have to
um i'm also just going to buff a lot i
just have every buff now so
you want to use aku sugar divine
confetti
and as soon as he does this you can run
in an attack
that's his sweep attack he only really
has one warning attack
when he runs away he'll follow up with a
fire attack in phase two like that
but the principle remains the same if
you see him use his firearm use the
umbrella
if you see him jump in the air use the
umbrella
has to be the fire umbrella by the way
so i do understand that getting the
upgrade might be annoying for some
people
so i'll try not to use it now and um
i'll show you what to do
he does a double head slam sometimes
okay it's a triple head slam
that's something you should parry
okay so if you don't have the umbrella
run away from this jump
and then grapple back in and you can hit
him for free
so that's what you do if he does the
jump without the umbrella if you don't
have the umbrella you can also just
dodge through most of his attacks
that's why i say it's like a dark souls
fight
all right so this is phase three now
here you don't have much time
immediately open your options and get
that yashariku sugar going
this will halve your health but with any
luck and male content
you won't actually take any damage so it
won't matter you just want the damage
here
so i'm going to use this and i'm
immediately going to use malcontent
you can use this three times in this
phase and then it stops working
but as you'll see when you do use it
it's amazing
so i use it here and i go to town
you get about 10 attacks in in the first
one
in the second one you get a few attacks
in and then you get stunned
and then you get a few more and that's
the fight
but um sometimes the fight will keep
going it depends on your attack
and how many buffs you used so
if you don't have malcontent i'll
quickly show you one of the attacks you
want to avoid
in phase three
[Music]
jump stand still jump
kill okay
now that you've seen that next is inner
father
probably the hardest fight in this
update
uh just because i mean father al
has a lot of attacks in general and they
just added more to him
but the principle from previous our
fights kind of still remains the same
you can stay at a medium distance and do
a lot of health damage just by
exploiting his attacks
like this one for example so i'm gonna
try and show you that now
that medium distance thing
um the other benefit is this arena is
much bigger than the other arena
so you have a bit more room to run
around
but just be aware that those follow-up
attacks are pretty brutal
when he does firecrackers you can
actually dodge through them or away from
them
but through them is a bit better like
this
so i'm just staying at medium distance
now and this is one of his new attacks
whenever you see him do that i mean
we'll talk about it that's one of his
new attacks basically
but you're seeing already it's harder
this fight
but the principles are the same however
if you do want to fight him which i
recommend you learn because it's fun as
hell
um this fight gets a lot more
complicated he gets a lot more moves
and i'll show you those now
so let me try be aggro here
so i mean it just has a lot of
exploitable attacks still but
he has just a wide variety of moves that
you sort of need to learn if you want to
go toe-to-toe with him
and it's just so much fun fighting out
like this is probably my favorite fight
that's one of his new attacks for
example quite brutal
so if you see him go into the shadow al
form it means he's about to teleport and
attack you
usually so honestly just tap block don't
do anything else
because he'll almost certainly teleport
to you and beat you
when he does that you can jump over it
two attacks and then parry
gets you a ton of posture damage
block block i saw him go into the black
form
jump attack attack attack and
that's phase one now phase two is the
same as phase one but he starts using
the al as well
and depending on the way you see it like
a lot of final phases in this game
it can actually be a good thing like you
get a free attack in there when he goes
into the blue hour form
sometimes the out gets in the way but
other than that it's not a problem
you can dodge backwards from that you
can dodge forwards when he disappears
he's blue owl
get a free attack in after you unlock
and he has a fire owl as well
which we're going to see here the new
thing
is what i just showed on screen the fire
owl
used to have like a warning
jump thing you had to do but now the
fire owl also has a
sort of vertical attack where you dodge
to the side so
if you see the warning jump if you don't
see the warning for the fire owl
dodge to the side
but that's basically his new attacks
um the shadow oil thing
can throw you for a loop until you
realize that you just kind of have to
block it
and that attack can one hit you if you
get caught so firecrackers are pretty
scary
it's kind of funny that they're
overpowered for him as well
jump it's like that's like parry
he just turned into the blue al when it
starts when he disappears completely
that's when you know he's turned into
the blue l
and that's basically our father
um remember i'm attacking him you don't
have to if you want to
you can play this really safe and just
stay at that medium distance until you
get the attacks you're familiar with
he always follows this up with a mercury
or he almost always does
and it's very generous block uh a very
generous counter so
yeah so he went into the shadow out i'm
just tapping block this will get your
posture pretty high but
it usually won't deplete it
jump whenever you see the sweep
and i mean basically just gonna let this
play out now
i didn't do that quick enough i think i
have time to heal here because he turned
into the owl
jumping over this he didn't follow up
there but that's fine
whenever he does a shuriken like that
he's always going to do a jump attack
and that's the fight guys and
that's almost everything that's every
one of the three gauntlet bosses
but there are a few more bosses in the
mortal journey
which you will unlock if you complete
all of these
so let's go and see what those bosses
will be
so in the mortal journey there are a few
bosses that aren't in the other
gauntlets
um let me have a look i mean you have to
fight basic ghanichiro
you have to fight the corrupted monk
which is the phantom form
you have to fight the headless ape duo
and yeah that's basically it except you
also have to fight
basic eachine inner ishin basic father
inner father
basic kenichiro inaginitro so let's just
do the couple of new ones so that's
headless ape my least favorite fight in
the game and i'm sure you guys agree
on some level this fight
i hate this fight it's such a like i
know how to do it
i know some really good strategies for
it but even then
that's no guarantee you're gonna beat it
so
basically you just want firecrackers for
this and also
you want to have the ceremonial tanto
maybe i like having that
and you also want the um loaded spear
but i'm just gonna
skip phase one because we all know how
to beat this guy it's the same thing as
before
block the sword use the spear whenever
he does the slam
and he's dead okay so when you do
finally kill him
that's when you want to use the
ceremonial tanto in my opinion
because we kind of want as many
emblems as we can get and he'll run away
and you want to get some follow-up
attacks if you can you'll summon the ape
friend
that was a bit of a scuffed way of
summoning it but whatever
and then the cheese begins if you're
lucky
run around to the battle arena and try
to avoid them
until this guy does a scream
and one way you can sort of trigger him
to do the stream is by attacking him
i think getting at least one attack in
is good
but get more if you can but you know
you can just run away and when he does
the scream you hope to god this one's
far away
and you just do this
and you hope that you can get the kill
i did it so that works a lot of the time
if it doesn't work what you should do
is use the firecrackers more sparingly
and just use them every like 20 seconds
on the brown monkey because the brown
monkey doesn't have much health
okay so what you do
is you just run around the arena until
the brown monkey is far away from this
monkey
maybe this monkey does a scream maybe
this monkey does a big over committing
attack
and then you just fire crack of the
other monkey and
you start wearing it down its health
that way like slowly but surely
that is the other way you can do this
fight but i'll skip ahead of this
because
uh we've seen it already before with the
guardian 8. okay
so the next boss we want to fight is
the corrupted monk and i think this is
really the last fight i really need to
show you
oop not that one this one
so the corrupted monk is basically the
true monk a bit easier
especially easier because you can choose
the hell out of it which
i might even recommend if you're on your
if you're on your mortal journey you
might just want to cheese this
because mortal journey's hard enough
already but run around to the left side
of the arena
if you do that carefully you can
actually get some extra hits on her
and the cheese for this fight
is a combination of snap seeds which you
can use and then attack twice with
use attack twice except for the third
one where you can only attack once
so remember that and then you transition
to firecrackers
which can be used until you run out
basically
and this is exactly the same thing you
can do for the true monk if you want to
uh if you accidentally do a sweep attack
just do one attack
and i mean that's the fight man i'm just
showing you the cheese because if you
want to fight the true monk
you can do it normally but man just
learn this fight though
don't cheese it it deserves to be fought
properly it's so good
i just love when she does this sort of
loop
you can dodge through a lot of the
sweeps like that and get some health
damage in
that's it guys hope you enjoyed it was
fun commentating live
i can't wait to get to the end of this
recording and see that something's wrong
with it
although if you're hearing this i guess
nothing was wrong with it so
yeah hope you enjoy the video this is
going to be a weird one to upload
people are going to see it and be like
why is it an hour long
oh well the start of the video is just
news but this
i hope was helpful to you guys so until
next time
peace